[Music]
Pikachu we play this game do you ever
actually watch the gameplay are you just
on Twitter all that [ __ ] all the time
whatever I'm trying I think I didn't
pikachu it literally goes into get
killed so you can go back to the
internet that's what I think yes no he
wants like he goes like he wants I'm
coming he wants Pikachu our the entire
time you know that's what he wants that
is not what I want I've been streaming
all day okay yes how do you all the
powers getting I chose our xbox flood
12g with Koch Craig and pika when you
were doing it with yourself what did you
try to get Pekin friends
yeah Pekin friends they are friends it
was just a you a narrow most of you just
said you can't arrow yes they do we
fight talk more about arrow that we did
before you jumped on are you talking
about price I hope arrow here is that no
Steve he already knows mean arrow good
buddies will see it's gonna be like
[ __ ] Pico to Wow think
I don't just run in this time Peaks just
like [ __ ] that I'm just telling you
right now Craig I'm not gonna be the
first one to die all right let's see
okay let's see what happens you're the
first one to die what are you gonna do
you gotta you gotta make it up somehow
if I'm the first one to die I'll take a
leg kick from coke well Dave you said it
no I said it but I would not to go back
again on that kick no bags some boxes
what let's go here okay no backsies you
said it alright if if I'm the first one
to die then I'll cook we'll be able to
do something if you die first you have
to participate in the weight loss
challenge
I mean you are Marty's loser I mean I'm
already losing weight so like I don't
listen in it listen Venus I just thought
to do do it with Griffin dude it goes
that's right shad hashtag Craig is fat
oh we got a couple they're going that
way so let's keep it tight let's keep it
right here let's go let's land more
towards the shoreline all right okay
now I'm not letting can't kick my legs
and then you say oh we got a lot of okay
you better hope you don't die man they
might be going Mansion honestly
when I hit these houses right here so we
don't just [ __ ] yeah you do that we
do that so that you die that's right
guys team Griffin Craig are you afraid
that Griffin will lose we're no new map
yeah it's not just what we got we got
two people going to where he's at
dude there's hella people here who [ __ ]
yeah you're right he's right in front of
me [ __ ] that let's go I'm coming to you
Kok let's get out of here or nose the
back house is back houses oh yeah it is
running the back house coming can
lightning kill you that'd be awesome
that's right that's right jive Turkey
team Griffin yes see the thing with
Griffin is is not just about exercising
you got to eat different and you
different what are you talking about he
do my shake every day much if anything
Griffin's about a [ __ ] Griffin's got
a [ __ ] kitchen and he gets groceries
he even talked about if anything that's
what you need to worry about I'm not
worried about that [ __ ] all right let's
go myself
should we go yeah it's good I didn't
know well Craig you still gonna get
kicked by coke
stop get off the [ __ ] thing what do
you do and do if you're gonna hit us I'm
not
hey don't be mad that you died first bro
talking to dirty not you
we didn't I cook you didn't have any
guns right so you're gonna get fun I
didn't have it a gun yeah I didn't have
a gun
don't worry Pikachu I did it so they
wouldn't kill you if you could report
bagging and you get banned for a couple
days I want to finally be Helios I think
when you back when that happens though I
think you can report your teammates now
jeez really
that makes sense so cuz if you're
playing with random do that name [ __ ]
new man anyway dude those guys are go
were closing in on us
well didn't kill me son didn't count bro
you did so now it counts now we got it
now ya know we really see
Scarlett Johansson cast as first blade
black Johansson cast as the first black
James on that there's so many things
wrong with that article from that it's
from the hard times on that
Oh dad there's a hurricane in Hawaii
I hope those people are safe Baroni yeah
that out suck why he's been getting the
shit's with the volcano and everything
to you
someone commented on their stuff they
say the man Craig so salty I'm probably
you know what's the noise the sound of
lip smacking from Craig yeah irritating
bro
yeah I'm people going on Twitter yeah
let's go pinky
no one's walkie yeah poor [ __ ]
smacking your lips something that ate
mom's lips and not the top ones if you
know what I mean you guys know if Dustin
Poirier maybe other store
yeah this nurse there's so many people
the [ __ ] it's fun disgusting
I mean I hope it still happens I mean I
understand why they're mad that they're
not on the connor card you know what i'm
saying i think they should be it's a
perfect setup on whether if Connor loses
or if Nate wins or you know you know
what I'm saying mm-hmm
playing let's say you know Dustin beats
Nate and then Connor looses then boom
Justin could beep that's a good fight
right there and then Connor in it are
you playing the game or you just for USC
Kebede pints Connor and Connor makes out
with dude let's go [ __ ] playing the
game focus on that dying you're a lot
you died last game you can be already
dead
I wonder if make it's paid for
pay-per-views and that's why you wanted
oh that's probably why that's probably
you probably get he probably gets
pay-per-view points I mean yeah there's
no [ __ ] guns here she's 30 come come
to me come to me I'll save you oh yeah
good luck it's you I think we're good
[ __ ] I cannot finally come to light
I got a pan and a [ __ ] helmet that's
great alright I'm going up this building
dirty Oh No there's a guy on me Craig
I'm coming but I got a pan I literally
got where is he Koch he was expecting
that [ __ ] that [ __ ] was so classic that
was so funny dude
hey I was like its it was like what hit
you no joke I walked up and popped into
the head
that [ __ ] was too funny
oh [ __ ] dirty we'll be fine
she's in Charlotte no more them we're in
the red zone good look man did this guy
have a backpack no he didn't know all he
had was hit yes good good
it was so funny because he was just
watching you and I love literally like
right at him I think he was it nobody
expect that [ __ ] like so he just comes
straight ahead put the pan with somebody
else is Kenneth or where do you think we
should go I have no clue you and dirty
no no it's [ __ ] dick all in the same
[ __ ] area
I was too many extra guys there's
already went to those houses dude there
ain't [ __ ] yeah
I haven't check that house - you're
right coke I'm gonna go to that one I
was too funny [ __ ] I wish we had
recorded that she wears yeah well you
know if you decided to move your editing
setup
could I capture that wall bro Pikachu
I swear to God
let's sit here right in between the
school you see what I read mark teacher
I know what you're doing looking
crouched and the other way this house
had been looted there's a drop over
there at 290 I'm following you so let
him find out how thank you
yeah [ __ ] that guy was like I think that
guy like he saw me right it was I was
swinging it was like it's it's like to
say he must have been so mad at dying
that way them out of it so eager
somebody hit me with the frying pan Wham
momily think you started this [ __ ] looks
like it's either being little or no now
I know it's might be getting looted
right now yep 6e there's a there's a
squad here voice I don't know if the
answers I don't have much on the screen
here trying to flank there's one going
up top there going up to the right on
that Ridge he's on the right by that
Ridge
yeah I don't know where they went - you
[ __ ] owe him behind they pushed in
was that you were they in the building
they must he was up this ridge he was up
here he's up where you are right now
Koch was right I jumped down yeah jump
down the ridge that claim you can kinda
he's coming he's pinned me down
he's stayin still if you guys get a
cream shop yeah I'm working around back
to front he's running to me
I seem to Craig now you got this
straight ahead of me at [ __ ] damn yes
he's has an SKS that's why [ __ ] you man
I got him it's not another one coming
Craig's dead body yeah I see would you
told me that before I got clothes dirty
I got an m16 there's another one another
one on you Pikachu
yeah get [ __ ] done get [ __ ] you got him
yeah good job Pete you got one right who
died first great you did yeah what's a
help dirty thank you though and durgi in
a crossbow so that's so it was funny
that's all yeah I know it was funny to
watch you fire it though like boom
that's right Thank You Chad I don't
think there's anything it's worse keeps
you glued everything from that body well
the one guy had an SKS well I need I got
the SKS but I need ammo man ain't got
ammo for any of this [ __ ] I have seven
six - anyone need seven six - yeah I do
I do
yeah I could use that sucks without a
scope man
no thanks Craig no nice you didn't do
[ __ ]
you just stood behind Jenny might just
turn around and the guy was hard trying
to hardscope me and I shot him so I
killed Len dude look at myself you had a
shotgun because thanks to dirty at least
telling me you didn't even know what was
happening yeah well that's what
teammates are for it's called you know
team game right I had to shot
I think I should have murdered you I had
no problem shocked I had no problem
shotgunning you nightly already they got
all this said yeah maybe we should hit
water rooms I'm thinking
[ __ ] I don't think I've got a policeman
song no I don't I have a boosters for
you cook if you need him come to me
buddy
what is it those deer like uh energy
drink or pink oh oh yeah you know same
as you pick a 2d fool I would say that
it's really good it will like give you
hell for so long
hey what's up you unique tag what's up
bro we should probably hit oh you dick
right here on me a sit right here
Watertown beat you behind me have a
shotgun I have a s12 k that's fine
I think so you need
is that the automatic failure yeah no
it's not
to be honest I feel like maybe I might
have been able to save cry if I came
sooner replied cut up it yeah if you
actually like good stuff
that's right maybe Cerritos I'm gonna
watch
that's right want to watch Pikachu the
whole time and see what happens to bad
peeps get some kills let's see how it
goes
why you running in the coke no what's up
to the nine people watching us
you look us up this Friday
that's not an S k12 was that's not
shotgun is it
maybe it is police mess over here
check upstairs first dude I don't like
doing that hey you want coke to get shot
know how you work
let me pick up this mister
but do you have a pistol make sure you
coming into my house trying to leave my
house there's a car here there's a car
25 there might be people at the other
house yep there's a little - that's ok
cuz anybody ok I got five five six
that'll go we'll do something
anybody have any 762 big I think I just
saw a girl whenever I got I got some 160
not for sure
three two of em yeah they're all right
here to 285 I see I remember when we
played that first game yeah yeah if you
have a shot Pikachu what are you doing
you're an idiot
I know and he did it with the handgun
dude I swear to God watching I just give
me some with the [ __ ] shotgun and
give it away positions with the handgun
and getting shot in the face okay I'm
coming in go help with Peaks
I am I am I am yeah Pikachu where the
[ __ ] are you Abra you shattered thing
from where you're at with your guns oh
my god so I got your data those
House can come in your house big
tailpiece say hasta la vie I'm gonna
talk man pizzas the worst I had the guy
killed Pikachu on the building next to
you guys
so he'll be coming from the from behind
around about three yeah they're gonna be
coming up the stairs again yeah Billy
yep there's a galton window and to get
you doing all right careful careful
don't be too close to each other they
might throw nades up there well I need
to he like if they had him they would
have right they used to love these and
on you Pikachu yeah he's he's coping
he's so picky yeah still there
naca nice ok I can't get the angle I
think in the crouch throw it you got the
Crouch but roll away
you think I can do it yeah there's one
going around the car you gotta go higher
okay I tagged thank you
alright he's running around he's running
a lot around left I'm gonna put him off
here doors open that's me - he's trying
to circle around he's here nope yeah
down me he's stuck out of movies I know
I was not expecting that
I don't know I swear he's gonna he's got
med kit yeah he does good [ __ ] okay
he's got a bunch of [ __ ] for heels nice
good stuff guys we're doing great
[ __ ] you Pikachu the worst
I watched you give away position with
the handgun for no reason it'll read
that on a handgun and he's shooting the
house across the way the guy's not even
out there by the way the guy went in the
door and he's shooting the door like
hello guys want to find
oh my god
hello yep there's a guy you've killed
and then peek do you need top and save
her or anything dirty um I've got yeah I
do thanks okay hey here come here
jimena dirty where you at what's your
snipers right now you want to ask I've
got a suppressor
I got a suppressor on my SKS right now
oh yeah hey dirty just just do me a
favor check Pikachu's thing to see if he
had anything abused and all I didn't I
didn't I just want to know what he was
running with I'm moving dirty come on
have a syringe though a syringe they
have any other guns I didn't really have
much they had just a bunch of heels I
got a bunch of something hmm
I'm getting shot at go in the water they
can't hit the water
let's change the be used to dirty
Loudoun all right let's go look at these
other UFC immense well yet dirty trying
to balance I still had a shotgun and
that starts coming Peter
and I get in this all you got a car
Nanyang you gotta hit it storms here
dirty you're on it
[ __ ] I need helmets you better run bro
you guys got a little weights and travel
I'm in circle almost
I'm crossing
you guys aren't you gonna get the car
what what I don't know yeah I got the
night Donna it fells off to the left are
you gonna make it dirty yeah yeah he's
come out to heal Oh Peter you have to
cross father oh yeah yeah yeah that's
what I was saying
don't die dirty come on America
and steroids dampen Jesus I'm in the
next what she does he doesn't really
want to play he just wants to like play
to die and then go on the internet that
is not what I do
are you sure that's what you just did
I'm pretty sure that's what you do is
you're really something you're really
something like he literally is scoping
from a rooftop I don't think there's
anybody at this bridge is dirty so if
you can see vehicle you shouldn't have
to this bridge yeah if you can get over
here I have first aid I got a med kit
too I should be able to get you from
well no not strong touches it's gonna
it's gonna hurt real bad
you have anymore heels yeah yeah he's
healing right now there he goes
I can do it I got it I'm gonna get shot
I don't see anybody
yeah she's got some some big ones
I'm gonna drop these for you I have to
go now to first only woman that wants to
make out with the 12 year old peach is
that yeah I've been going well for us
okay you I mean governing extra scopes
I've got here there's the third time for
you yeah you need to compensate her for
a are there you go no do you want to
suppress again you want to suppress it s
you've not already on CD
oh this is a cool email rest in peace
Harambee let's just run this this storm
this right side here let's try to get
high ground on this hill
how weird is it I think there's a guy
yeah laying down when you get down
behind not rock to you right laying down
30 degrees okay Oh where's he at 30
degrees laying down I say two of them in
the crossfire let's do more
it's bigger too gonna try to understand
yeah can you try Pikachu and like how
people set it click the internet
intensity dream but the questions and
all that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah he can
leave it up he just gotta [ __ ] play
the game yeah you know I'm playing the
game I've been playing all the time oh
why is it out yeah playing like a little
[ __ ]
come on Peaks okay ready up
oh yeah
now listen about Pikachu's face I just
want to smoosh it are you hungry yeah I
probably know beer right that's what you
guys make
what happened just a loaded slug
we should do to catch a predator with
Pikachu just make him the bait hi my
name is Pikachu I'm 12 catch a bunch of
creeps trying to get it on with him
if I start with banana I'll be the first
guy to show up or Pikachu
all right let's go where we landed we
are landing
all right let's [ __ ] do this I'm
ready let's go there's my dude let's do
a Nova Nova Scotia run deep
alright let's do it I miss Nova that's
gonna be like yeah yeah because you're
probably [ __ ] jerking it to some fan
we got on our [ __ ] thing pay
attention I want to go to those houses
on the mountain you know those two in
the back yeah the back the back houses
yeah that's cool yeah
you guys see anybody I I don't see
anybody
I see people people one two three four
five for the interlining in the shipyard
thing in the containers let's state the
house I don't want you to stuck so like
seven houses over people yeah take the
houses their daughters it needs to
render in though there we go okay give
me a UMP and two m16 let's go good stuff
there's another guy landing and it's
dirty there's another guy landing and
it's dirty he says
who's shootin That's not me and it is
not me who extended quick-draw let's go
there's these girls that shot guns at
Lois I don't know where it was but I
think it's right under me I literally
have no guns dude there's a lot of
people here there's one at 260 they're
throwing throwing grenades I see in the
house ones by my house that's yeah I
sell one by your house he threw he threw
a grenade downstairs hello he's on me
all my god he's got the automatic
shotgun yeah that's that I didn't even
hear him dude didn't even hear all right
I'm a rescue crack shut up I'll leave
rescue why don't you rescue co quickly
someone's an [ __ ]
I have no good guns I'm gonna come your
way I just glad he's on the router of
this house isn't one more in here just
if I could find a shot yeah good
all right I got something for us guys
here we go coming to you I'm no more
ammo you get them oh where did that come
from
they come from behind me there's one
more in this house ah I just had a
handgun by at least a shocking he's in
the house dirty I get you guys that kill
yeah yeah watch out he's coming in your
left dirty
he's coming they're all on that door
head waiting on a whole different
squadron upon us
that was too funny and that you guys
likes nobody here then literally 8,000
people I would have had that guy find
out a shotgun I just didn't have any
good guns well you just have a [ __ ] it
takes a second sometimes for everybody
to low back in relax bro trying to focus
now so toes on your rabbit what color is
Peter what's his deal
Peter is gray he's a hollow lop rabbit
he's a why haulin lop kind of Holly
blopps does he do fall in love fault
from Harlan Harlan mom oh he's from
Holland did he smoke weed what color is
he grey it's a very rare color
his mom's and white and his dad's black
how do you know cuz I met them
domestic rabbit boy that goofy looking
huh
hey you me tell you talking [ __ ] about
my rabbit cray
so what so what do you do with Pierre I
can play fetch without the ball like how
do i back out of this hoe the start but
it won't start
yeah and then leave Matt okay she's like
you never played this game before
okay I'm kidding it's a joke it's like
something you would have said to Holly
lock it's hauling up oh your family had
a rabbit named Peter nice yeah that's
the name of my rabbit man Peter no joke
ready up big boy big boy he says really
really big long ears yeah yeah he likes
you if a rabbit likes you and he wants
to show our affection towards you it'll
start liking
dude Peter I'll be the help nowhere you
probably told me the new craft I'm not
in your family yet
Craig ready up I thought I did
they'll be cool is like right when I get
it on with your mom's and then she's
just like whatever you want Craig I just
start making your life super difficult
wouldn't even happen bro you would whip
it out you'd be like where is it they're
all that girl with that gut you have
Craig can't find it to be like damn it'd
be poking out of her guide if you know
what I'm saying
up in them guts up in them guts
this guy says it right here is not
plastic how big is how big is he eater
how many pounds did you say he's pretty
big when he passes away are you gonna
make retention that's a big there's ones
where they're like they're gigantic like
if you look up giant Hollin lot rabbit
they look like [ __ ] dog like there's
one bigger than your dog coat and just
like flops cuz it doesn't even look real
bro it looks like it's like something
from like a movie or some wizard [ __ ]
that's awesome
[ __ ] huge and then just imagine that
[ __ ] but if I'm sprinting that should be
scary
you guys want to try this foot place
again
yeah okay let's go should be free we
just gotta pull that chute soon now
let's do it
when do I pull the chute now now and
then float at 20 kilometers per hour I
mean as long as it's below 30 between 20
and 30 then that's how that's how you
start slow
then we said these things and you have
to get it over here
Craig have you ever had any pets not an
iguana what happened to it
that's all did slide it sold it cuz they
live for 50 years dude and I was like I
was finally like I denote the guy for
like six years of my hair's too long
damn and you can't have dogs
I like playing on my family's dogs dogs
I can't I don't wanna I'm on
what kind of dog do that Pikachu I don't
have a dog
oh I mean I do it I don't care what it
is I mean I don't care about it so I
don't go [ __ ] [ __ ] that dog that's fine
that's [ __ ] I mean I'm just like pop
too early
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna go over to
staying on the road and try to find a
car it's always the same okay I talked
too early not gonna I did that great you
do that you do that every time he's
talking about why I jumped out before
I'll come because I was a problem that's
okay I'll meet you over there last night
who would I get I got a shot off our
shotgun hand on the pump bust another 40
humming Oh blood
wrap all right there's a scar here
someone coming to me
dirty
what's up you're coming to me there's a
scarf I mean we all know I'm probably
gonna die again like maybe one kill so
you should pick it up good night
you're not even kidding yeah no one can
the main part of the city actually there
might be a lot of people I didn't look
I usually land right where that marker
is yeah there's a car that's me
premature premature parachute ejection
that's Craig
thank you yeah okay I'll take the vector
nice I got an Uzi and a vector I'm ready
to [ __ ] die it's pretty much the
truth I don't coming to you guys
we had an old-timey shotgun
oh [ __ ] I'm in the [ __ ] red zone
that's not good you'll be fine bro
I don't know if I will to be honest what
I'm like it like just started as I left
the house and there's no cover here
I need a cheap pad if you guys
doesn't mean I wasn't I was gonna I've
never had it before it's the are or
something
come on buddy almost up that end of the
red line such edge oh [ __ ] there's a
dude right in front of me - Craig McCaw
come on that's that's trying it for the
same well try it when he's right in
front of me home oh I don't run up on
him we go almost almost like if Craig
were just [ __ ] all where we fall
we're coming we're gonna rest Cullen
he's in this house behind me
Thanks
where's that correct where's yeah what
number you know he's in the house behind
you to you there's no house behind you
here yeah you down below where dirty is
well we're in the same house that dirty
there's an SG pick up choke here and you
won't need that or though shotgun tree
there's the level twos there's two level
two backpacks in here
I already got back thank you
nobody wants your bitch-ass my level to
you helmet up here I'll take it where
Charles this case use if that one a dad
21 at 2020 okay all right let's get the
vehicle let's mob show you go pick up
coke what yeah yeah go do not an SKS
let's go down alleys others ask ass here
why didn't you tell me that crack come
on let's go man I'm gonna meet some
sights
I need sites and armor does anyone need
a quick-draw man for AR dmrs ok
okay [ __ ] you actually way out of the
song huh mm-hmm hey let's uh I'm gonna
take us to a fast livable spot and then
we'll come and pick up coke stuff the
blue coat
oh yeah Oh guys want this car yeah Craig
get the car get the I don't care Craig
get on the car
why we need to vehicles if you want
Craig to move majority this first
come on Ron dude
two pieces that could possible right
there yeah you know I tell anyone across
the level to helmet thank you very much
another scars here coke do you need a
scar I'll take your scar
well I can't pick it - pretty far away
well that helps me - thanks
appreciate it there's a level seven you
want it take my humble and basically
I need scopes that's what happens all
right
are we gonna go to the zone soon yeah I
come pick me up you can take that truck
Pikachu you
I'll go get coke I'll go good coke you
go get dirty anybody finds scopes I also
need a vast if anybody sees a vast
anywhere I'm still got five for you
I got mmm come on all right after work
for now Coakley put a dot on the map
ooh what do we have to go well I put it
that where I am at I'm coming to you I
need to know where to go after I pick
you up I'll just drive dude hey dirty
can you drive cuz I'm bad
yeah there's so much by 5:00 in here
they came
but we got to go the Blues coming bro
yeah switch so it's to let me drive
all right so yeah you put it up yeah
yeah I'll be did you have a ping killer
enough per se in energy
we don't crash
oh [ __ ] oh we're on the I will be I
asked will be yeah I just don't have
don't forget abyss the grow use the
booster snaps crap we're gonna fly like
a [ __ ] that cinder sand it sand it
yeah there we go
made it see don't worry everything
always works out boats plane right there
oh jesus oh Jesus
I mean it looked like you should've been
able to get out that but not so much no
we're back in the bleep you did you
watch that watch that industry that's
what happened hey I'm looking at this
dream right now and we're getting shot I
just saw it now how was that like a rock
that was like a little blanket sir it's
my fool who was bump and it thought it
was like a rock and they'd be like yeah
yeah but it was it was a tiny one like
not even like those solid where's that
boss I'm over when I'm over
your dad Craig they're all behind you
bro I had nothing I could do dude I was
already half shot I was trying to run
away let's do one more we gotta do one
more that's a terrible way that daddy's
gotta go to sleep bro die daddy's got
week Emporium you got one more well cuz
turns I'm dashed oh now he's blaming oh
then he's throwing you under the car
fat Peaks pH that piece okay piece of
[ __ ] yeah that's not weird
that's how we your mob huh yeah yeah
yeah sure we've been dealing all week
what would you do if you found out me
and your mom or D I'm in peace
I don't know nothing my mom's an adult
she can do whatever she wants according
to Steve you're not though so I don't
know hey don't be talking [ __ ] about
Steve clothes for a standing double
backflip no no that's the world's first
all right let's get this track
Cokely ever play any of the doom games
the new doom is gonna come out
mmm I played them before but not crazy
oh [ __ ] we're in a game let's go where
can we go somewhere where there's not
like 8,000 people right we all know
what's gonna happen Craig you're gonna
bounce surely populated spot yeah yeah
yeah that is that you're going to the
drug dealers house let's go why don't we
go here I don't you can't really
describe it
we got a weed I try says we as soon as
you can't just start by tapping X and
now keep doing my peer miles between 20
and 30
this is the slowest right Craig doesn't
want a bunch of people so this is what
you get he's like we're gonna land on
the game where the were the four this
Craig why isn't it next to us do you
premature again I'm behind you I don't
see doesn't he doesn't wait what the
[ __ ] behind you now I'm literally like
right next to coke and dirty
you guys stand about ten seconds this
were correct I'm gonna go to these
houses here I'm not gonna okay I'm gonna
go look at this I'm gonna turn around
the camera and you can see where coke
and dirty alright and then look what
Craig is you can't even see his [ __ ]
parachute then take me an hour to get
there dude it's just fine that's fine
see over there
I'm going down at 13 miles per hour
pretty very that's actually though yeah
that's a no said 20 between 20 and 30
dude like you said that so many times
Oh 20 30 can you hear can you hear okay
and there shouldn't be anyone near us
right right right
hello
I'm not that far for me but I'm gonna
hit these houses before I told you
sticks between 20 and 30 and I'll pick
you up cake that's okay just
I'll meet you we have time we're in the
zone by the way you're in the zone we're
not yeah
Craig's like you know what I don't even
want to worry about I want to land right
out of it all right let's [ __ ] go
let's go you got this whole thing to
Rader
dirty you don't want to hit these houses
real quick over here know why this is
like when they're in big cities like
that that's there where they are you
sure dude we're pass on to beautiful
look I just gotten them for just like
that oh yeah big cities have tons we
could do mm-hmm
any places like that the chances are
very very
that's 200 bucks Oh AKM tell you guys I
suggest ya 31 honk let you know we were
coming I just I just need a bad bag
oh my gosh we've a pistol and a silencer
for it
and energy drinks for days
[Music]
what was the other m4 it's in the house
that I mean it's low it's on right in
the entrance
I just need a gun period
I don't know [ __ ] Don Smith there's
that hump on me I take that always away
when I'm 16
look his houses are [ __ ] empty well
that Jesus bad energy drinks for days
there's some painkillers
what are you turning some I'll mark it
on the moon I need a
there's a vector there's one at that
there was one at the house it just have
like a little one upstairs okay I marked
a yellow we get a car right
yeah there's cars nearby there yeah yeah
this tall this tall building to my right
dirty is where the UH okay
ooh another energy drink Jesus dude
unloaded on it
I got a silenced mm4 now got a four-time
school
I need a stove stop
I got [ __ ] yeah if you find the Nexus
scope yeah I gotcha
Oh oh my god do you need a gun Craig
there's like there's a hump in here
there's Busey there's hella ammo AKM
I'll take the OP I can't find come come
to the church come to the church there's
an AKM cuz I'm I'm gonna run I'm gonna
run back there an m4 yeah I like a cow I
don't coming
sure does ablute is the half grip good
does anyone know that is that a good
attachment repeat recoil control recoil
recovery weapon steadiness is that
better than the other way I don't know
much about the groups I think that is
the better one you sure
where's the where is the everything in
here it's in here come in here where
where's here I am mo thank you
there's a job somewhere we're gonna have
to think about moving here oh thank God
I didn't my baby
maybe there's another Craig Craig come
to the top of the roof where I'm at
level three backpack I'm good you hear
that Jack Craig let's hear I'd rather
that basketball actually don't know this
I think I'm I'm okay to go now I don't
know I just I don't have a lot of I mean
we're gonna we're gonna have to go
that's well we gotta go now we gotta go
now who's got the cars come on if you
hold why it'll make you yeah I know I
know I need five five six bad yeah both
my weapons are five five six let's go
something going on you dirty you guys
can go thirty there's another vehicle
but wants you with those dirty let's go
let's go let's go let's go I just felt
fun no no I'm driving through a [ __ ]
city you guys take so long to lose you
oh my god
we're dead that's not it was like one
second damage
watch this there we go remember how the
last came into the rock peaks right here
well that house right there okay hit
that shade on me no because it's not in
the zone there's nobody over here Dave
we're so far of course co-star hawk let
them know we're here though they were
doesn't matter cuz I got the gun skills
to to him I'm saying
white cloaks building anybody finds a
better um everybody finds a scope
does anybody know stuff for smg's I just
need the vector so I only have I don't
know other slots I got you but I need
you want to extend in my when I got that
I have extended mag everything you have
the scope I just need the last part the
first part the vector in the last part
after the stroke I don't know I have a I
have the coffins they're the first
person enforced our stock and then I
have the last part I have a compensator
for an SR and I have the foregrip for an
S I think we should go here
I'll tell you I see where another Craig
got eaten if I okay the compensator
guess see where I'm uh that's where we
see that sitcoms there a flash hider
yeah okay yeah I'll take you doing
who wants to go dirty
I got a silence p18 see now baby
how do you boost again lb lb LM thumper
yeah
shoutout to the six people still
watching us
do you think there are people here coke
I'm scared there might be see them
who's that other cars huh is that that
that's yeah
Oh got hung up on [ __ ] literally
nothing there's a car here what else a
good partner
it's their car right
I mean where should we go I mean there's
45 people left I'm going over here so
that's 41
how many nobody a little ammo and stuff
should we just start playing lame and
wait to the very end or what I mean I'm
good I'm good but I'm also thinking this
place will be it's more central in a
circle and it won't be leading that's
what I'm hoping
yeah no Stan my expert expert driving
third just come to where out on us all
right that's fine
we're gonna get the houses [ __ ] it then
close that door behind the beach here
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm the [ __ ] they still shoe nose
she's still just unloading on my car
not if it could give me a [ __ ] scope
that would be fantastic
I'll take a 4-time scope I'm gonna loop
more of this well they're gonna come
here with [ __ ] grenades and
everything chisel hose me get out of the
way here they come
you don't need to go up here Greg
they're coming I'll see them at a woman
car we gonna get it got a three time I
got a three time does anybody want a VSS
but it's one of my favorite guns I don't
want to use the scope I got in a time
they got out they got out they got out
35 35 yeah there's another crook on -
they're gone another car coming your
house he passed are you using that no
you can have it give it in here you go
I'm gonna drop a quick anybody need a
thumb grip - I dropped one bring the
barn yeah we've been here at the entire
[ __ ] plank Jesus well we have a car to
leave if we need to leave there's one at
the other house that was that
we're right outside this circle we still
having do we still have a truck any
chance yeah let's go in your truck okay
there's a box up there they're going
towards 305 305 I've gotten on that hill
oh pretty far Oh Greg I can't even I
mean it dude I have a red dot yeah but
no bending you're standing right in
front of me bro all right we have a car
but I think one of the tires might have
gone her I'm moving out man I'm just
moving on earth what'd I do
I'm trying to kiss house I'm trying to
keep him off this box I think they may
have got it yeah they did our car in a
gunfight well that's you
I hit him out scopes I'm full
I just need scopes I can't see [ __ ] are
you oh [ __ ] I just got black scream
hello I'm not even joking I got a black
screen of money from joking I pledge I
got black screen where are you in the
car he's loading back in I'm not even
bullshitting you I'm not even trying to
like I know I shoot I'm gonna take us
four times because I really need it no
wait you might get back in
yeah I'm looking back in we will you're
supposed to be like oh you're not gonna
get back in I'm moving towards a circle
though alright we're coming
I'm moving up to this compound in a
marketing shop I know I should shop
Pikachu [ __ ] take it one more time we
might have some he's best on the moon
it's definitely been alluded what about
that building to the left that's outside
of the circle
they're here come on knocking at 3:40 at
3:40 there's two moment on you
yep I I hurt ones underneath you dizzy
yeah we're underneath can I see him I
see him
we ran through
Oh one's on me
I knocked him another one on me Craig
[ __ ] where is he now he's right on the
edge this isn't so dumb lately all right
everybody just try to hit him for every
one of their kill now yep scroll in I
want him to come in yeah okay I'm here
Jesus yeah ah [ __ ] [ __ ] man goddamn it
I'm coming I'm coming
he's heard okay did you get your collar
kill who's right there why did I call it
in [ __ ] kill me
he's right there right where you're
looking there is it you made out right
when you looked yeah he ran right there
that's up Pikachu in the daddy we ran
right there where are they where Eric is
going oh I see I see em nice neat
healthy I'm coming I'm coming I'm here
he's on the other side of that building
for YouTube not this one with the next
one yeah he must oh there's another guy
intergenic oh yeah yep hey could you
scrape the left side get up there there
are another one that hit me that hey get
on the left side of this building
Pikachu not there's no other way around
okay scared he's right there to your
right
no not right up there really cause it
got wailing I feel but I don't think
that's him goddamnit cuz there's like no
one coming
no wait hey Eric there's another guy
behind you in the field way out there by
those that heard your shots yeah like if
he sees yep Pikachu they are dammit
Pikachu I swear and he's hitting me
those Pikachu I'm done playing that's
the old day that's a figure to that gun
although can't reach that far like you
at the ain't pretty you know you you
know do you do know that I [ __ ] I
kill do a blue blue and now I get
leather [ __ ] because they know where
we're [ __ ] at and I'm running out of
ammo Oh
we're gonna be able to taste a good
decoy it's not because I'm getting it
I think I'm getting some from them
I had no yeah or they're shooting at
depth if you hold down head or feet she
knows how to do it that's close
oh my god that one is right there guys
no helmet no I didn't I [ __ ] hit him
twice
and I didn't miss how do you like that
you did it dude when don't when I'm
close
that's how I prefer it oh thank god
there's more I think I hear more yeah
yeah I do but I needed the ammo
yeah Pikachu still alive because I'm bad
this game I've like not good there he is
really bro that's [ __ ] dumb
he's down eyes there you go nice what's
happening yes don't don't even remember
dude there's another dude I think know
how many kills now this is just wiped
out a full squad yeah Pikachu what was
that moving you would judge dredd
remember with like Rob Schneider like
did nothing that's a Pikachu he's like
the Rob Schneider tier Judge Dredd or
whatever
I'll have Alan he literally yeah I'm
loaded on five five six I needed it why
not
what's this article I don't know guys I
know who's coming in I'll check it after
this no you know there's definitely yep
definitely some that's I hate where
we're at right now I think there's
people up where that truck is on that
ridge line try to get this a rock okay I
got it
lease Mina reload you get you see what I
deal with
yeah like I'm killing squads and
Pikachu's running around in circles
okay I'm telling you I'm not good game
I'm like the worst yeah what can't game
picture I want what game are you gonna
put them on maybe I doubt you're even
good at that
oh yeah I think they're their eyes he
gets you go help and I'm looking get
them up yeah i QE i know dirties gotta
go can we do one more just us just want
to try a little more that's [ __ ]
I got drags about getting hits on
somebody in this thing who brags about
that I'm so that what's the way you play
you getting hit is like you spraying
[ __ ] six to eight hours in land
- m5 as long as it hits mm-hmm no wrong
tree that's not fine can you good games
I'll be but I'm sorry you had to play
these alright see you guys
I got you dancing so we got we got to go
to a populated area here alright alright
you can chew I can't you gotta get in
I'm sorry coke like I'm not good you're
not and you know at least the admit
fighters I'm not good this game I'm
better probably better at four night
without a scope um I'm kind of useless I
mean cuz I can't see that wall without a
scope Lucifer I'm a pretty good backpack
though I mean you guys need a bank bag
are you ready up now or what happened
I'm ready let's go go no joke
ready ready mm-hmm
[Music]
all right this is it we'll do one this
is our last match this is what we're
gonna get our chicken dinner guys
oh this guy looks good hold through 187
I bet he's gonna win the game for us
okay he's ready guys we train you
Pikachu no
all right Craig I'm just letting you
know I'm not gonna die before you and I
will help hopefully all right hopefully
this is this is this for real because
just me you and coke if you die before
me then you have to get a leg kick from
coke no what the [ __ ] oh I love it I
love it but there's got to be incentive
for Pikachu if you died yeah all right
Pikachu
I'll buy Pikachu some Gerber baby food
you piece of [ __ ] you really owe me
money for breaking my phone yeah I told
you send me the bill you [ __ ] yeah
that's that about didn't even break it's
cuz your baby arms couldn't carry your
phone that's what happened a slightly
true slightly true
god it's this map again [ __ ] I'm never
good on this mouth and do you act as if
you're good on the other one
I might be slightly better it's more
familiar where are we dropping side
warranty
okay was good a lob rented I can't even
see it because the lines get in the
[ __ ] way indeed have indeed it's hard
to read it's hard to read when there's
lines gone through it I said so it's the
problem I'm disagreeing um I think we
should be good I don't I don't know if
we'll have to pop them early or not yeah
I think we're gonna have to I'm popping
my
[Music]
what's wrong
are you [ __ ] me are you [ __ ] me
yeah yeah oh you did squats - Craig you
didn't do three man's blood for I'm just
gonna lie my ultimate he seems pretty
cool what makes him seem cool Pikachu he
had like it's 180 and he's 187 the code
for murder
borrowed are oh this is cool this is
like broken down planes in [ __ ] see look
he just killed two people one person
hello whoo yeah we're listening why
oh man this guy just dropped a scar for
me this guy's a good teammate
are you gonna blown Pikachu okay why are
you laughing you do that every time you
play with Gavin arrows or shut the [ __ ]
up
oh he's so salty really he got a bat if
you said that deep but those footy like
like areas he was deflecting well you
matter you blow guys all the time too
but I'll find a rifle at a time again
I seem to might we might do good at this
game for this match this guy's too good
he's the good yes and he's better than
coke is that what you're trying to say
that's a stretch coke is pretty good I
mean yeah I bet if coke played there's
like even like consistently all the time
good pretty fun
let's welcome back back now here we go
okay I'll put that swap this out
actually
we're the circle that's big news
our ultimate is still looting I'm on my
way to you guys I've got an SKS I'll
stay with him
well I need a backpack so don't go [ __ ]
I need a backpack really bad
I need a backpack then I want a better
gun that's me
the [ __ ] a backpack [ __ ]
I know about [ __ ]
oh here we go Oh too bad I got one I got
a level two also I'll keep a Novak [ __ ]
right 187 killed
gunshots Tom's gun shops no he goes he
said gunshots I know he's not even
biased there's two fries no that's what
I'm saying he'd get to grab one there's
a level two best in here
where are you coke right here oh I got
backpack [ __ ] with me
thank you fire pan need to get like a
any kind of [ __ ] actual like rightful
the longest there's a [ __ ] ton of
backpacks where I'm at
what kind of scope you got I only I only
have a [ __ ] you got taller
no I got a four times but I'm not giving
it to you till you find me a gun I'm
kidding honestly I liked it three times
more well I got a three times I'll use
the four times but I need to find it oh
[ __ ] did Oh and boom there I got it four
times anyway I'll take that water to
himself um I got it so just come find me
I just need to find a [ __ ] any kind
of like actual gun gun all right
Ultimates making its way towards you
guys
[ __ ] man all I gots a [ __ ] shotgun
did you check all these houses Craig on
this side I checked the bunch of rooms
in sacrifice their shots you shut up
already with the shots
yes shots at 2:25 I'm saying about he
doesn't yeah yeah I hope you don't know
you're to mid
[ __ ] man I just need a better gun dude
you can't do anything with just a
[ __ ] chocolate there's two cars 280
they're going to where the explosions
are in the tower there's a lot of what
what are you saying
I know that's what I'm saying
don't worry bro man pulling it out here
come here come here
oh oh yeah you see any other guns all I
got some SK 12 dude it's not gonna help
me
now I haven't seen [ __ ] I'm trying to
run to help Altman I feel this pain see
Peaks you so bad at this game it's just
people are popping off on Alton I see
him but they're fighting each other
though I'm gonna try to get the ultimate
citizen the other guns down there dude
well if you go on my BA because a star
if you go my body there's a scar I don't
think I can get to your body dude you're
[ __ ] up there's a guy going across
come on West
barking I hear them I not go home coke -
you're right you don't read next to the
palm tree that's not the car all that's
missing
oh he's gonna know
you might kill me I need the scar though
it's I don't know why it's not hitting
there it is there there's so many
[ __ ] over there Jesus coming
back to you how does that not hit bro
that was right over him
hey you stack let's watch this ottoman
dude he's trying to push up and go on
and engage them I need some 7 6 to my
body there was [ __ ] onyx and I think
maybe like 20 I don't think I have any I
don't come on cook I did go to your body
to get the scar needed that how many 7 6
- I got 30 here coke I'll take it
I just dropped it right little help
that'll help a lot there you go yeah
there you go yeah I mean they're coming
out I get it
taking the ultimate house
yeah I think you should have stayed with
ultimate dude all you're gonna read some
terrorism how does that not hit him I
hate the SKS dude it the bullets it
takes so long drop to the trots move
let's get out of this red zone here
the pictures like there's God's activity
to 275 they're not anywhere near us
it's at this little compound or coming
up on right here I killed one of those
guys
why did I
this looks clean too
you know to to to data that have a dead
[Music]
turtle with you
I don't think they hit this
and some more sentences to
I'm gonna call you know I have I need
more five five six if you see any I got
I got some I got sixty rounds if you
don't even take it [ __ ] well I think
I'm gonna think I'm gonna need it
because there's an m16 here alright I'd
rather have it over this bill but this
UMP see you ain't gonna do [ __ ] at range
all right fine take it and I don't have
I'm gonna put any time on this [ __ ]
we're outside the circle right right we
got another sit two others hey there's
an AKM over here 760 - I got some I'll
give it to you okay just gonna loot
these other houses there's a level two
backpack over here a bunch a
nine-millimeter I'll give just need five
five six you see it I need I mean yeah I
got I've got to get him out oh here we
go got a scar over here I'm sorry I'm
gonna have mini-14 mini-14
ooh I'll take that I'll take that it's
upstairs here
I don't need this 45 ACP
you wanna 6-tier I'm dropping I'm
dropping this or nothing
I don't need this 760 drop 763 okay
now I don't need me I'm 16 oh but if you
have bullets for it that you don't need
right do you need those bullets now five
five six what
yeah I do for the mini okay I don't mind
cuz I got both I got both of them I got
bullets oh that's fine that's fine
they're both that's fine yeah those
snipers just asking that's me this house
right we do this one expect
[ __ ] to start coming in
yeah well trying to at everybody
everybody loves this SKS man I do not
like it takes way too long for the
bullets to travel they hate hard but
their bullets do not travel fast
oh I got seven six - yeah I'll take it
use all of that it's better to have the
light grip or the vertical foregrip I
think the light grip here I'm in here
where you going
yeah taking this own substitute
it's it all right be careful we might
have people coming out mr. zubi should
we go somewhere else or do you want to
camp here just wait
if I'm gonna go on a Mac on this
building at the second floor at least I
have some news on them I said a marker
we're gonna have to travel through this
town
oh yeah you gotta go and we don't have
vehicle doing well it's not a working
truck
I hear shots I'd Toto cat air to to to
to to
[Music]
- me too me too
[ __ ] let's go further around let's take
these hills to the right I'm coming I
don't I don't want to go through that
[ __ ] I know there's [ __ ] in
there I wonder if that trucks working
that's a working truck over there let's
take that just be careful it could have
been left behind by people more yeah
over there mmm also to toe to toe
look like this place been looted
that's it's a little shack thing I think
we should just get moved I think this is
a natural spawn
I have to go to the back of that I'm
trying to just keep it yeah keep these
hills and to keep us hidden a little bit
no I'm with you I'm just thinking if we
can get to the back end of it but we
still not looking this trucks awesome
dude I was flying with it he was alive
nope yeah what's his name died oh wait
no you were going down we're going down
towards the city we don't want to do
that right now we want to hit this I'm
hitting this blue this blue marker
there's two it's all down there
yeah it's treeline yep oh I hear a motor
something that neck that store right
that bike is gone yep did he stop I see
stopped at those building I see somebody
at this house at 3:30 yeah yeah yeah I
see you
see man that's happily
yeah he's running whoa watch out he's in
that he's in that little middle brown
one little brown in the middle I think
they're leaving now yeah he's going on
the right babe
oh we're right by the circle we should
probably get moving towards it right
away
establish the position
be careful to the left yeah might be
someone on that ridge line I don't like
this like I'm the elephant no but I'd
rather move to these buildings before
everybody all right
go into that double-decker house yep
careful mm-hmm
now there's a helpful I don't where you
go upstairs really sent me
yeah but there's a health and I don't
think anybody's
nobody on the left nobody on the right
all right
let's keep this building yeah we should
have the bandits shooting from the
hilltop there yep
circle is going to start moving to
that's silly right yeah 190
and they're popping off over there
see
it was a blue I see one running across
this field 335 going west I think he's a
little far out I'm gonna I see him he's
laying down yeah oh we're right at the
edge of the circle dude see where it
goes
watching it back I hate this gun dude
that's KS thoughts compared to the mini
bro there's one he stuck yeah bite come
on yeah yeah he's gonna frost us he's
gonna cross no he's going across yep
he's got a buddy on he's going to us
[ __ ] we're real tight like we're right
on the outskirts of the circle right to
our right
that was me you go let's go to these
drums see what I'm talking about
not down there's still a lot of dudes
alive they're certain to drop now though
just wants behind us yeah I'm gonna
watch behind us because if anything they
might come over this Ridge yep there is
right behind us to hit him he's hurt
where does he know they're coming behind
you to know the whole clip I take them
down
[ __ ] thanks for kicking up the stream
guys I'm terrible at this game wait so
now you gotta kick Pikachu in the leg
first coming for that leg breast-high
you on top let's kill let's kill this
for you to talk with you
[Music]